ah yeah it's the bee sting king in the
Rat King
[Music]
what up dog what's up playboy not much
bro
well can you see me yeah I can see what
are you talking about Oh oh good you've
been on set are they remaking hook no
I'm remaking are you all bang rain Rufio
from hook hang a rang bro hang a ring
Rufio what are you talking about my
handicap i'm palma your ipad yeah i have
on an eyepatch dude I'm challenging
myself because a lot of everybody's
always running around with two eyes look
at you guys
look at him [ __ ] with both of his
eyes Oh a bunch of [ __ ] weasels bro
and it's time for you guys to step it
game up and challenge yourselves you
know have you ever heard of the guy who
fights with one hand behind his back
nope well there is that guy he's around
and that's who I am right now and I got
this eye patch on I'm rolling on one
today dude you know what I'm saying I'll
[ __ ] all y'all up with one eye bro yeah
man yeah yeah I guess it's cool I
figured you came off the set of hook the
remake or Pirates of the Caribbean
you're like an extra in your Johnny
Depp's part dude there's some there like
Jack Sparrow side well why do you hear
about it there's oh do I have to realize
it sorry
you know you got full Hollywood I'm
sorry I was even talking you what'd you
say I'm on the cup no it's my agent
yeah we're live Wow well except for what
hey comes with a [ __ ] bedazzled
eyepatch in ear buds Wow bro you gotta
go hard these days you know you gotta
challenge yourself and I tell that to
everybody all you young men out there
and young women and and people in the
middle of them you know mix crotch bad
boys out there what I'm saying is this
challenge yourself okay tie one of your
legs behind your back you know put it um
tuck your dick between your legs and
Bulldog your nuts
yeah for a day yeah for yeah they live
check it out walk backwards you know
what I'm saying do an eyepatch tie one
of your hands so your mouth shut yeah
glue one of your arms to your side do
different stuff and challenge yourself
don't just be doing what you're doing
all the time man it's inspiring thank
you very much man I appreciate it bro
that's that Rat King boy you know some
time that you know I don't need two eyes
bro
you could not and I'm trying to clown it
you
could not look any more like the
real-life Rat King from Ninja Turtles he
has an iPad really I think so yeah
something over his eyes at all dude I'm
devolving right into true life I'll be
real racket MTV's new series it's
getting bad here and now some over his
eye yeah he had some real he had some
issues - oh wow similar his legs - very
nice legs but no I look I'm just yeah
look shit's getting hectic out there you
know and I'm ready I'm training for the
end of the world
dude you're shooting right now home bro
you were shooting a pilot for the tummy
central for Comedy Central how's it
going it was good do we have bas Rutten
on the other day love boss so much
energy yeah yeah none of those sounds
dude boom what is he [ __ ] out but is
that how you I got fired or did Johnny
Depp busting you actually what happened
was on the makeup girl used like a bunch
like she was using dirty tools oh really
yeah and somehow I got infected or just
all read or it got scratched was she's
painting your eye she's just putting
makeup on the front of me you know
nothing heavy you know nothing illegal
but just fire her huh oh yeah she's not
there anymore so you know I'm saying you
can't bring dirt to people you can't be
an e mais you know yeah you got it guys
are kind of important yeah I mean I
don't need them all the time and I'm
probably got one oh dude I drove here
yeah oh we go about an hour good an hour
yeah the five minutes I had to go oh you
got to go slow of one I won no laughs
for you no all right oh it's Dave all
right and you got to lay on the horn
while you drive - thought you're hooking
up with your girl - dude one-eyes man
drive you nut
anything could happen dude you just
thought was a girl with a shaved head
but he's just a full slave dad do my
girlfriend in middle school had the
shortest hair and uh
she would always try to kiss me really
hard whenever like F right at the end of
school and the school bus would pull up
from like the older kids school yeah and
all the older my brother and all his
friends would be
and they would just call us just it was
yellow all these gay slurs at us really
cuz she has short hair because she had
short hair and I had short hair my
feelings Canon I heard but she was also
very strong and I wish you wouldn't she
tried to kiss me like kind of a CrossFit
girl but from back then oh dude she
would like kind of pinned me against the
wall and kind of kiss me she was very
she was a grass yeah yeah it's your like
lift me up on door hello damn I shoot
lift you up yeah that's cool though if
that's your thing you can do nothing
about it I felt like I got taking
advantage of yeah she was a she steal
your milk at lunchtime should I'll take
you can eat your comb bread first of all
you can eat joke comb bread don't talk
to you unless you use all of the letters
of the alphabet okay milk and comb bread
aren't things let's get on with this
show don't my my first kiss I was dating
a black girl and I'm she was the hottest
girl in class in middle school and she
wanted to kiss me in front of like the
whole school and yeah I'm down for this
[ __ ] some big old ESL's I was like oh
I'm gonna be the SL she was you're both
children it sounds like so six grade
okay but deal sells you dude let me just
put it as a little kool-aid lip never in
my life have I ever seen DSL on a sixth
grader okay
no will I ever look at her so I was also
in sixth grade so at the time that's the
reference
okay this sixth-grade Brendon okay
that's where okay so she had them
kool-aid lips with the kool-aid smile oh
yeah and we went to go kiss each other I
was like everyone's gonna think I'm so
cool and then this kid Cameron Wilson
he's kind of the bully hold my pants out
in front of everyone while we're making
out dude
heartbroken why I'd be the same since
bro really no I could see that that
would that would really long bro damage
I've ever launched me now a real wish
and well of pain yeah I'm alright now
let's get into rip my drift
I'm kind of sad now yeah we're not doing
rip my drift today well yeah we are we
are you know we have some fan
submissions we can't do rip my trip with
you because you have an eye patch and
that would be a soft so let's get into
the fans first all right this one's from
young HBK alright well first of all this
might be the best rip my drip cuz he's
wearing Jordan Concord Elevens which are
so drippy really super trippy ah bro you
could wear those with a tuxedo
you could wear those on the blacktop you
could wear those two NBA game you'd wear
those to a nice dinner you do anything a
nice dinner where name a store jealous
if you were sneakers to a nice dinner
bro you wear join 11 so Chili's you get
a full free record and an awesome
blossom they look stolen they don't even
look like real shoes you what a store
that's what's a little suspect is he's
trying on shoes but he's taking pictures
of them and then it's like a cat in his
well true it looks like he's in some
sort of oh he's trying to make himself
look cool by trying on the dopest shoes
in the store and getting pictures of
Mali's there he's like yo Saturday kicks
of the day like sha but you don't know
you got to own the post bro the other
thing that's where do you have ak-47
hanging off your dick bro does you
really don't go get your [ __ ] gun out
my face bro you got that's assault rifle
yeah that's from and listen let's uh no
I do like the black on black clothing
I'm not mad at the outfit at all and
then you know be a BM f stands for bad
[ __ ]
man come on bro it's not get your ear to
the ground of the kids these days dude I
can barely see I know so put your ear to
the ground cuz you can't see what he's
wearing
that's a good point actually yeah I
probably should listen more and but also
this man has a beard there's way too
many accoutrement it's got like a damn
Christmas tree you know he's got his
nails done first of all zoom in on those
nails please well manicured
and it's like a taupe kind of paint he
has on him okay enough we had claws
that's gonna be a nada for your boy even
with one eye I wouldn't [ __ ] you know
try and sneak around with this guy a lot
of families max yeah that's a hard pass
so let's go up he also has the BMF he's
got the eye glasses indoors
he's got the borrowed shoes he has on a
babyGap hat and he's got the beard it's
just a lies got the gun on his day look
he looks like a member like he's part of
the entourage for a [ __ ] catch me
outside girl it's not like that he looks
like the security going for catch me
yeah it looks like a barred baby uh
entourage er and he looks like a UH
he looks kind of like a Saudi Arabian DJ
Khaled hmm I can see that will Tanner
you know dude but another one another
one
boy another what boy what that's
Jamaican a Sierra Leone brother no she's
Jamaican okay look I dumped by the beach
I'll take the country with me everybody
in Jamaica is always trying to get you
to gamble place a bet with me man really
know those who smoke with me mom those
turn flares a bed with me but we're to
make it did you go let me tell you this
I work to play clubs mom there's no dude
there's trying to pay their bills
brother kind of hey who goes with your
money dude they will see they're having
skis no brothers so I went into a
Starbucks in Jamaica one time right yeah
the Starbucks on I go in it's not even a
Starbucks they just stolen a sign put it
out front
Wow yeah I walk in the ladies like do
you want to smooth this uh they don't
matter cheeseburger mom at Starbucks
yeah you're mine let me get you some
mahi-mahi no game I like what hockey
ball mommy jerk chicken on this that man
ice came here for a dark roast no dr.
Osborne
watch your mouth Paco no racial slurs
here man like I know
dark roast coffee I'm not kidding Rachel
yeah sure one addresses us out of our
mind I'll get these conch fritters yeah
dude it was crazy and then Rosharon
Pappas I walk outside and two dudes are
fighting each other with knives here's a
knife fight right outside of that like
it's just I mean the thing about Jamaica
is it's experience after experience back
to back to back until you're dead and
what were you doing out there I was
there I think I was going on a cruise
and uh Jamaica sounds awesome oh dude I
don't like it it's too risky man you get
out and about West yes it's like who you
gonna call be in trouble
nobody No Christ you're gonna call for
help yeah and they also have all kind of
strange deities out there and stuff
they're burying each other and I mean
somebody killed Natalie Holloway out
there so let's bring up the next one
camel they got booty like this
[ __ ] oh dude voodoo is the word
out there
oh it's in voodoo chicken tenders bro oh
wow oh damn dude she what's her name a
little dude that gender Ella that looks
like you dude hold up
she looks identical he doesn't have to
bring this reference up from the sister
from Incredibles the one that disappears
she looks identical bro okay the chemo
sister that disappears first of all this
is a young man oh it is yeah 100% dude
so first of all you should know genders
before you go dude before you meet
anybody on it and when she's emo bro hey
won't you check in with your wife see
what her gender is because you should
know genders dude okay dude sometimes
she does the hug her doesn't he she look
like her dude are you sure to zoom a
little structure what's going on there
arm though you can tell a man by that
arm look at that arm
why the apps kind of do it for me a
little let's see that ABS second that
video there and the hands are tough
the hands are tough I'm really hold on
now hold on look at that arm you think
that arm is on a woman bro you know go
just elbow down please chin it does look
like [ __ ] flying Tomatoes arm it did
white it looks like Shawn one looks like
a man's arm guess what if something
looks like a man's arm it's a man's arm
dude you know what's that look like a
man's arm a woman's arm you might be
right let me see the ankles chin let me
see
oh he saw him up on the toe like yeah
he's playing a warm floor and that's
like a lot of you see a lot of Commander
boys walk around like they got that warm
floor syndrome lava lava floor bro yeah
yeah oh did I do my second yeah get to
safety
Oh fell on your dick yeah Oh fell into
your arms you know Oh filling your lips
fell into your family's inheritance and
that's how they do it and these boys
slip around like that now get up on the
on the gullet again let me see that face
and neck dude let me see that the Adam's
apple no oh you know to tell okay what's
the name chin Alyssa 25 years old what's
the first name Randy is it Randy Alyssa
what solisten Stamper ow ow I mean ow
are you sure it's not yeah
I'll Lysa it's not the purple monster
for Monsters Inc
I can't see but I would say this very
beautiful young man or a woman either
wait up it's a handsome or good-looking
creature look at the posture I don't
discriminate yeah I don't discriminate
those tiny little shoulders is it a DB I
don't know oh yeah I don't know not
watch this young lady chocolate off her
shoulders on her if you ever done that
chocolate shoulder challenger you put
like Hershey kisses on your shoulders
and try to eat him off without knocking
him out without raising your shoulders
you have done that yeah I'll do I'll do
one next week yeah let's do it but yeah
a beautiful young man or woman and nice
to see them today let's move on all
right the next one is John
love addressed hold on go back one time
for that other person the same one yeah
is this somebody's hey well dressed like
a [ __ ] homeless four-year-old I
forgot to rip their drip you know we
didn't rip their drip look likes just
robbed [ __ ] hot topic
we're just offender in their gender well
that's art we figure that out first
though
like I was detectives here bro yeah oh
yeah right I just start with the case
yeah so you figure out what what's going
on exactly and then I get my drift
yeah this seems like a young man or
woman that's about three years old and
got up in the middle of the night to get
a glass of milk
and now is [ __ ] 31 years old looks
like she worked at Tower Records yeah
yeah this definitely but seems like a
really someone that's probably very
sweet and does a lot of nice stuff for
others on the weekends let's move along
change please boy non-stop John Legend
Johnny's eyes Swedish in Mexican wow my
combo that's a la somebody [ __ ] on a
boat dude that's not a cruise ship
that ain't no land baby this fella son
yeah he's a water baby international
waters oh yeah dude I know two things
rose
who told you put that on here's the
cowboy hat in the back and he seems like
the kind of guy that would take his
Grimm was one of if his grandfather's
ashes and put it in a mixed drink and
just down at a party see I was gonna say
looks like you take his grandfather's
ashes and snort them oh you put him in
his booty hole yeah yeah this guy seems
like a really kind of a nice guy that's
you know probably a maybe fifth or
seventh year college yeah did you go
yeah he's like now he's a coach yeah
he's a Van Wilder of JUCO college yeah
just keeps repeating
I mean coaches the women's softball so
young [ __ ] the girls I got this guy
figured dude he has a tattoo on his back
says get your motor runnin but he seems
like he lookin you see his legs or not
he's thinking as a [ __ ] stamp
Yeah right type of feller to have a
[ __ ] stamp isn't a frat many moons ago
but still hangs out with those guys oh
yeah still still stops by to make sure
the chapters doing well you know just
following up on my brother yeah
dude he was your kind of guy yeah he was
GHB himself at a party bro dude who did
it oh I'm acting crazy just wake up
enough in a UH it just wake up in a and
in somebody's family in a different
place only have one and I I know but
that took away yeah well now I know what
it feels like to be you and be very
limited you look look he looks like he
calls himself Frank the tank
I thought he looks like based off the
movie it's like all right bro we all
know that [ __ ] guy he looks like the
life of the party though yeah he does
look like the light of the party he's
got a mullet what if he's deaf does it
say P's hearing impaired doesn't say
that dawg that's a great question he
looks like somebody they also could be
deaf or gone it really were blind
really yeah with that time the color
combinations a lot going on the cowboy
hat in the back he thinks the regular
normal baseball cap he dresses like a
senior citizen but with a [ __ ] hard
[ __ ] he does you know bro
he Dre he seem like a used car salesman
let me tell you this about this young
man if you look at this guy you can tell
that this guy obviously
probably has some pending me to charges
you know he just has that kind of vibe
but you look to me looks like a rich
dude who makes horrible investments like
he invested in flying cars 20 years ago
yeah like he invested in glitter mines
which is something that up we our family
lost about two thousand dollars in
somebody came to our town with a glitter
mining thing when I was young I grew up
in like the pyramid scheme bail make
sense oh dude if the second you even got
fifty dollars he lost at another pyramid
scheme hide you know he looks like that
dude though he looks like the guy whose
family invest in blockbuster two years
ago okay he looks like you know he looks
like he looks like the coach that lived
from that we are Marshall movie Oh
he does a little bit he's got that vibe
he looks like he'll tell you his best
high school days whenever you ask him
yeah yeah it looks like he definitely
he's obviously still wearing all of his
high he looks like he still wears his
high school ring is class ring yeah yeah
and he tried to give it to his
girlfriend and she left him because of
it but he also seems like a good guys
got a nice chef Errol but I'd like to
party with him he seems like type guy
would buy a beer
oh yeah and what's his name John Lithgow
no John Legere 'im young he's also from
Oahu if that helps at all yeah whoa
this is getting interesting it's that
pineapple I need this that pineapple
cowboy right there dude he is a little
Moana cowboy
okay Leland stitch cut bro oh he's in
that Dallas citrus Club bro definitely
he's vitamin C you and see you in your
dreams it's that GHB bad boy you know
yeah he's that Hawaii five-o bad boy but
he's got a bag of hot GHB pills in his
butt right now he looks like the type
done name oh he's that border jumper
dude hell yeah it looks like he kills
all the hogs in Hawaii oh yeah hog
hunter who's too into it oh this is hog
the Bounty Hunter right here this is
shot out to that guy I should move on to
that guy time to pay the bills
someone's got to pay for Brennan's
coffee habit you know what deal what if
I told you listening to make you a
better friend even a better parent
although you have no kids I'm a dog or
cat
I think I have a cat all right might
make you better owner no promises better
leader just a better person overall man
all you got to do is start listening to
books bro oh yeah I need books man and
sometimes I don't even I can't even read
them that good cuz only have one eye
right now now you do have one eye makes
it tough well don't worry about that now
there's audible yeah with audible you
get access to unbeatable selection of
audio books including bestsellers
motivation mysteries thrillers they got
it all man yep and I actually do have a
book from audible it's about sexual
dysfunction that I'm learning about
right now that's cool man either must be
an interesting book audible members can
choose three titles every month yeah one
audiobook and two audible originals you
can't hear anywhere else yeah because
you can't drive and read think about
that and you know you might as well if
you want to read but also be driving
audible helps you with that because you
can listen to a book you can learn while
you drive yeah you're in horrible LA
traffic wherever you guys are traffic's
not good any big city you can educate
yourself while you drive bro yeah what I
do What's Up now mrs. fields really
seventh grade yeah I'm educating myself
while I Drive really fun of me miss who
the cookie lady well sit classes at the
mall accountable members can choose
three titles every month that's what
Brendan was saying you can listen on any
device anytime anywhere at home at the
gym on your commute while you're on a
hike or just on-the-go riding a horse
yep riding a horse riding an elephant
riding an elephant and a bald eagle
yeah or getting drugged around by your
friends sure listen to books all over
man you also enjoy easy audio book
exchanges rollover credits and an audio
book library you keep forever even if
you'll you know what this isn't for me
you keep it yeah you keep your books
Manny you know and instead of just take
imagine a bunch of books collecting dust
these books they're stored in a special
place in your phone in your hard drive
you can listen to whenever you want and
in your hearts yep and oh that's so true
that's a nice thought Brendan we want to
let you know right now that our
listeners can go to audible.com slash K
80s cats cats spelled with a k or
next K 80s to five zero zero five zero
zero and listen for a change
audible.com slash cats or text cats K
80s to five zero zero five zero zero and
listen for a change
support the podcast you guys wanna jump
in it debate club yeah hell yeah change
you yeah you bro I do it's [ __ ]
pouring outside still it is I'm getting
some airline
it's all dried out it's a little red
hopefully is it just the the inside
corners red yeah you're good though bro
but that patch is out the eyebrow it's
not jizz in there sometimes have
something wrong with it it's a medical
issue dude if it's pink I'm the freaked
out don't well she how much I can draw
my advice from Optimus square footage of
[Laughter]
three square inches of ice face yeah
watch only gets constant as I walk with
his hands in front of them the guy who
pretends he's in the dark all the time
just who said that i dude I'm right here
- oh God Thank You Marco my play Marco
Polo
yeah he's reading small fine print every
day of his life
okay snake no racist no racism dude I
don't believe in racism first let's
really give exist
KJ Lawrence what's up be singing the Rat
King got the bait for you boys some
really white teeth what's hotter damn
boy you got both homeboy oh yeah both
bro he's like he's like post Malone if
he didn't do all the drugs in the world
yeah that's what that guy looks like
this dude handsome feller has the teeth
and the eyes so he's went in in both
these debates beautiful young man teeth
are eyes bro and I'm assuming this is on
women I don't know what you're in or
anything I'm sure there's other women
your animals well I'm gonna go with
teeth really yeah dude if you're [ __ ]
up teeth you have good teeth right there
okay
see you have good deal races yeah I
embrace it as an adult make sense clear
or you had the Mele rocket teeth all day
[ __ ] up teeth dude there's nothing
worked really late a girl with [ __ ]
teeth looks like stone gang signs no
never seen that I've seen a little bit
of that yeah off the tin it's like the
city skyline on their teeth I don't like
oh yeah I got a little bit every month
you that movie Sleepless in Seattle
kinda that grill you know when the t-34
defence somebody's running a [ __ ]
nickel pal home ok [ __ ] Tampa 2 in
their mouth if the name the worst eyes
you've ever seen they're just like minor
Dookie Brown distracting no yeah but you
have eyes it just seemed like you know
yeah yeah you barely even notice your
eyes I'm eyes or whatever blue eyes
dude just I don't want to look at that
one okay I'll put the patch on it thanks
dude it's disturbing are your eyes green
yeah the great you're gonna look at her
steal yo girl get them emerald eyes bros
away from my girl man don't know what
the green eye panty-dropper in the room
you kind of [ __ ] yourself just
covering up one though now you got 50%
chance dude don't know what old holler
my eyes are you each are avert I didn't
know they were green don't you know that
they are you idiot you don't you tell
them little China all of those to know
what color my eyes are you thought you
Kurt Russell from Big Trouble in Little
China with I guess what people are
handicapped and you should start to deal
with that better do I know you had them
crocodile eyes bro the greens get away
from me what's up oh nothing dude why
don't you get all them deal Oh mr. green
eyes or check out all guys talking about
it guys I got these beautiful little
[ __ ] Cabbage Patch they got them tree
frog
teeth all day though well who is his
first of all this young guy he's coming
at that angle so you could tell this is
you know I mean he's got the beautiful
eyes a beautiful teeth I mean this guy
on mustache Oh he'd go for $2,000 uh you
know like one of these um
sex trade yeah one of these age you know
these a lot of these uh like gay eight
like Hollywood agents are buying these
men on the block your where yeah you
know he's that little dark way I mean
he's dead he's a damn dark red diamond
yeah he's yeah he's a dark web diamond
dude he's like the Bobby God tell me
Robert no doing drugs oh I have one I
broke
you know hard it is to [ __ ] do [ __ ]
with one eye you [ __ ] you greedy
person with two eyes
hey Who am I here you [ __ ] rob you he
that dark dot I bro just an
impersonation hole that's all yeah ma
doesn't go out tonight rope dude that's
a positive all of 1980s WWF right oh
that one spot I'll say this this guy he
looks like um but uh who's the guy that
got kidnapped the young lady they got
kidnapped in Denver young lady no young
lady Jesus this one I'm gonna ask you
kidnapped in Denver yeah he's that
[ __ ] job bro hold on you one I son of
a [ __ ] she got murdered
no one got kidnapped I don't know she
did no let's look back and see no we
found her body they found her bottle
they did yeah well over Colorado oh wow
the body was found clearly do some
reason okay well let's go look back at
the key guess JonBenet Ramsey this kid
is this could be John Manning that's
post Malone not on drugs
that ain't post that's post op Malone
bro this is JonBenet Ramsey looks
nothing like JonBenet will you pull up a
picture ever can't see real do what are
you on Explorer
he's on dial-up internet yeah girl oh
yeah they look exactly the same
the other son of a [ __ ] well look at
the eyes next to each other very similar
I guess they both have colored eyes you
can tell at the angle he's going at that
he
is probably about 570 that is the
biggest reach of all time on any podcast
this dude looking like JonBenet Ramsey
okay he looks more like Sherlock Holmes
he looks more like Morgan Freeman than
Jon Benet Ramsey no he doesn't look like
either one of those guys but look yeah
what do you say blue I mean obviously
it's like this guy's it says this is a
cry for help video this guy could even
be kidnapped because he's wearing no
clothes and he's in a small office
building might be fishing what was it
might be fishing for compliment was it
their eyes brother teeth I say eyes make
us look if somebody's eyes are nice
enough you don't even see the rest of
them not true really not true bro if you
have horrible teeth game set match the
over I mean how were sigh you've ever
seen beside your left eye right now name
the worst that you've ever seen
dude mama that looks like it was in a
gangbang right now and and just your eye
looks like that cameraman I got busted
on during a porno it's just a [ __ ]
it's not good
Oh what else we got you want see with a
fast head yes they chose eyes 60% told
you damn it's because you don't [ __ ]
up teeth bro no don't cuz you got green
eyes you eyes don't look at my eyes
[ __ ] diamond green eyes off my
[ __ ] [ __ ] what else you oh my god
this is my [ __ ] silverback gorillas
full-grown we're talking monster of the
jungle versus a full-grown killer
grizzly bear wins what's here the kids
use help is that first of all is that
his kid or a victim victim assume it's
his kid I don't know is it a daycare you
know I'm saying I grab some random kid
post them on the Internet
it looks it looks like a nice kid but
kid looks 17 oh yeah so what it what is
this guy ask a silverback gorilla or
grizzly bear fight to the death
we gonna go ahead you go first I'm gonna
go with gorilla because gorilla will eat
your nuts off your body preach I'll rip
them off Oh gorilla I'm off it's an icon
gorillas yeah they could take me in fear
like this oh good they really oh yeah no
bro I'm going good on my back I wish a
gorilla just give me up here just rip
the calm right out of me dude just yeah
I can drain that spinal pain in my ass
oh I guess over dude be I'd be 7 years
old after that and just take my neck
like a chiropractors yeah praise God no
need to teach a [ __ ] silverback how
to be a chiropractor how good would that
be Silverbacks Cairo dude
this is a brilliant idea I could see it
look like the guy who wrangles [ __ ]
scenario actually do you do with that
eye patch now you just been in the
[ __ ] jungle for years dude here's the
best thing of this you called them by
their first name or they gave me this at
all
Regent care I went to what does that
care place you stop at if you don't
wanna go to the hospital be here okay no
no Care Bear care you what what kind of
show you have how do you live all day
whenever you leave around other people
you just [ __ ] on your Jesus dude bro
we both agree silverback gorilla though
hope the fans are be with you too 57%
gang damn they're close though I knew
that 12 because a grizzly bear dude
don't allow it they you know they
hybridity take half the year off the
kind of [ __ ] do the teachers of the
wildlife they have summers off you know
I'm saying all these high they [ __ ]
slumber four months yeah then they
complain about work yeah did you have
summers off you have Christmas all you
have holidays off you have Martin Luther
King Day oh yeah and you're gonna
[ __ ] write the streets of LA bro cuz
you're only getting paid $17,000 here
yeah save it I mean the grizzly bears of
the [ __ ] earth man we wonder why
Humanity is dumb jeez Brendan let's go
what's another one art this is Jefferson
alley
hey Theo Brandon turbo tracking be steel
Jefferson alley from Westminster
Colorado
hollow born Denver Colorado as you may
know Britt Jon Benet Bell
got a question for you guys in debate
club what do you think is the more
significant iconic figure for their City
drew Brees or John Elway it's gonna be a
tough one
John Elway when he's from denarau
degrees from Denver dude so here's the
thing you little Louisiana slug rat
yeah you got a Louisiana rug rat uh
you're gonna aufstieg Oh with Drew Brees
right your hometown boy yeah yeah dude
he played for another team remember he
went to the Chargers they're like nine
not get enough here
beat it nerd then central New Orleans he
said great players on him great coaches
John Elway [ __ ] lives and breathe in
Denver Colorado owns car dealerships one
superballs any beat okay
he won Super Bowls okay that's not
anything so what is that a game at Dave
& Buster's
what I'm talking about is Drew Brees
came into a city that was flooded bro
there are water you know hardest to
throw a football when you're underwater
legal things goon time at the [ __ ]
hurricane goes her shut up about okay I
didn't do it but I'm saying this he came
in there and he won a Super Bowl and he
would have won five Super Bowls if his
coach wasn't such a [ __ ] egomaniac
how many did I weigh win Elway one three
and go chin Elway I'm I went to went
back-to-back 98 I think nine seven 98
right four
doughnuts one of my late in the run but
he won - okay - yeah he won too - well
look then you know what Brendan's ride
then I uh but who does he what his
question was an MVP his question was who
does it even but what city to me means
more to him drew brees did when he came
in you guys it was a big deal because
you had the [ __ ] high rain thing go
on it's called a hurricane you don't
like when I Randy's broke it's a flood
it's not high rain and I'll say this
drew Brees is five he spots two hands
five seven he's five seven dude I you
know what's funny when I first started
doing comedy I guess I was a couple
years in I was at he had just gotten
into town or zilart I think the second
day in town and this guy Scott Fujita he
used to play for the same yes took him
out to a comedy show and Brees was there
and nobody knew he was like no because
I'm right any idea yeah him from San
Diego and it was like you know they let
him go but it was it was like a Huey had
a bad shoulder he had that labrum he had
a torn labrum he's a Texas boy right
Austin and bro he was very was like
regular-sized guy man and so to see that
he's done that John Elway is how tall is
John Elway six seven six three built
like a Tongan went to stand as a spine
six three it went just Stanford owns a
shitload of car dealerships yeah it is
the gym for the Broncos now and owned
arena Colorado crushed that one all the
games all the [ __ ] big-time games
well I'm gonna go with Drew Brees let's
see what the fan said we don't with Drew
hold on even though I'm a Denver boy and
I grew up sucking off John Elway like
every other Denver fan did Drew Brees
100% cuz he is under six foot it says
six foot that's full of [ __ ] he's
probably 510 max he's always been kind
of the underdog and there was the huge
hurricane and it was such a big deal for
that city
Denver's cool man either way Denver's
killing it whether they win or not
they're good they don't give a [ __ ] like
New Orleans does all the women's they
don't give a whole array as all New
Orleans has is the Saints in Theo von
and Kryolan in crime and Anthony Davis
just left there you better leave easily
I can you guys suck with the
management it's all do you want say you
don't want some be in New Orleans to
play basketball do the Lakers baby I
don't like these stacked teams man and I
think it's disappointing that he did
that but more than I won in one eye
good well doesn't count bro now it's -
dude it's so crazy
nothing bro I have to dude it's so hard
to think with only with one eye covered
iPad I'm not even joking it is like it
like like I feel like I'm doing a
podcast with Mike Tyson okay let's see
what the fan says fans agree with you
55% for Drew Brees sang that's fair
better it is it is a better story it's
just a more recent story it's one that
people know but I'll say this the fact
that John Elway got 45% is pretty
magnificent you know try something to do
with the Denver fan but he hasn't but
even though but even he hasn't played in
12 years you know but he's so relevant
because he makes all the decisions for
the Broncos that's your point and I feel
like he handles it pretty well I mean he
got um Peyton in there didn't win a
Super Bowl for him paint won a Super
Ball he paints an easy one you with one
eye both your eyes were gone you could
hire Peyton as a quarterback right when
he got I was and I loved John Elway but
he's a terrible quarterback kind of
recruiter because our draft picks have
been awful that's why the team sucks Wow
Paxton Lynch [ __ ] Osweiler they paid
all that money that brought in homeboy
now that the what's name Kareem well I
was water sounds like a dog dude
Osweiler get this Osweiler no he's a six
seven rich dog can't throw a [ __ ]
football what else we got all right this
is from Robert B hey guys this is Robert
Houston hey don't do Bobby my debate
club is pubic hair on women you prefer
totally bald landing strip or full
thanks guys oh I feel sick bro why I
don't know just like the weather guys
look they asked I feel real sick right
now
do you yeah dude the guys were military
fatigues okay it's obvious that he is a
little more easier than usual six
probably a serviceman yeah
he's 16 he's trying to get some [ __ ]
okay he's 16 he's still trying to stay
involved with the opposite looks like
louis c.k if he went
ground for 10 years now he looked funny
like Louie CK looks right now after the
tough year that he's had I'll see this
Bobby I respect your search for adult
crotch you know or whatever
I mean bald shaved if it's bald bald and
that's illegal but if it's been shorn
then that's different and you seem like
that big bad boy that could get out
there and get off rodent so I could see
you four-wheel driving through some real
bushy bushy muff muff yeah it looks like
you likes it messy down oh dude you seem
like that swamp oh yeah I could see you
down there with a little match you know
yes he likes my wet diaper dude oh yeah
and you seem like a real I mean you seem
like I could see you [ __ ] pull it I
bet you like that Bush something a
pheasant flies up out of you know you
seem like that kind of guy he looks I
could just hide it underneath the sheets
and [ __ ] you all night he looks like
that big old thing that big old Rhino
doesn't he
things like that Rhino I just want to
put it down oh he's one of the big five
baby he's definitely uh that 4x4 he's
that rare element he's that rare African
element he looks like he drives that
f-350 diesel Oh duty death of a bitty
[ __ ] drinks diesel anata BTW is there
64 ounce cup of [ __ ] diesel and Code
Red right yeah it looks like tough dude
that drinks Code Red and and ribs with
the bones yeah oh he's that marrow
they call him marrow Street bro looks
like we gotta [ __ ] arrow Street yeah
he looks like the type of dude that has
all the pornhub accounts
I mean look no he doesn't seem like that
he seems like a good guy who's looking
for questions answered by two young men
that he admires and I'll say this to you
Robert feel sick thank you for your
service to our country you don't know
that he's a veteran I've camo pants on
he has a [ __ ] camera on doesn't mean
he's a Navy SEAL you [ __ ] but it's you
know I'm gonna give you a past you have
one creepy eye right put my [ __ ] bag
on bro I'll say this he seems like
something that could hurt if I see you
in camo I think maybe who served at
Chili's bro okay so that guy did he's
asking about shaved or hairy bushes do
you think he sir he seems like a nice
guy there's nothing creepy about that
no he reminds me of a guy I used to know
they used to run a nurse
a plant nursery and and that you know
actually was very demanding of his son
but that's a this is another new thing
Bobby what do I like I don't care man I
don't give a damn I do I don't like it
man you don't like that Venus flytrap
Harry I don't like that but it's coming
back and a lot of chicks are growing
hair around their butt holes - which is
like a new thing no no for me got the
Dingle berries it's just not my thing
that but muffler do you saying that
[ __ ] on that poot shoot clean oh I'm
talking that Brown odd mitten baby
that's what a lot of these girls are
starting to sprout back there especially
you see a gal it's about 30 35 40 here
bro oh dude my thing really hard pass oh
man I like that that looks like I do
with a hairy [ __ ] oh you like that
really can braid your [ __ ] hey man go
get dentures my house Oh mon Dieu $9.99
mine yet save us Jamaica we went to a
restaurant right we go in there's two
people sitting by candlelight that
worked there they go they're like come
in come in they turn on other lights
they go wake up the chef at his house
and I Devin come in bro took two and a
half hours to eat and it had all the
bones and [ __ ] I [ __ ] left it I had
to buy chocolate I was furious dude
laughing outside and got held up by
somebody up um and my buddy got all of
his [ __ ] money stolen Brian I going
back to Jamaica no live King and
stingmon
all right what else we got oh so you
said what I say Bob you like it here
yeah I mean I don't care I mean he threw
eight nine options
pick one no balls bald or landing strip
I'll say this Bobby definitely cement
the kind of guy that has a couple of
Polaroids of old [ __ ] from the 80s
[ __ ] uh taped up under his um the
flap in his car above he's like a truck
driver you open it up mister just
pictures of titties and no he doesn't he
seemed like a good guy probably on the
City Council what else do we want to
know Jim what was that what was the so
they're out of the to the fans picked
bald 63% were famous also never put a
baby emoji did they do that someone did
the hund it all right cat would
okay all right so the next one's from
John Krebs what's up baby girl that's a
good love that dude what's his name
John crabs and crab prince or sign
friends or Seinfeld here's my thing
here's my qualms with friends okay grant
tell me these [ __ ] five hustlers that
one was working in a coffee shop
one didn't have a job one was a
struggling actor you're telling me they
bought that [ __ ] penthouse in New
York for seven million dollars if they
lived in the five bedroom penthouse get
the [ __ ] out of my face man I believe
Jurassic Park more than I believe
friends I'm going with Seinfeld all
goddamn day but here's something that
might hurt your feelings about Seinfeld
was filmed in Los Angeles was it really
yeah Wow they said it was opposed to be
from New York lied and I don't like that
bait-and-switch kind of [ __ ] I know
I wanted you to have those facts before
you go go ahead I'm going Seinfeld I
appreciate that dude I'm droppin the
patch I'm [ __ ] this one dude so I'll
say this friends I've never even seen an
episode never never seen one episode of
it I didn't get it there's like a bunch
of [ __ ] you know it seemed like a
bunch of white supremacist hanging out
around the fountain in the beginning on
if you've seen that part Oh for you I
can see how you think that variant for
Aniston it seemed very uh yeah it was
just too much that it's too white
privilege from yes no one ever had any
concerns the biggest concern was [ __ ]
each other yeah and living in this
penthouse it looks like yeah and
everything buddy seemed like they'd been
to the gap or to structure I seemed like
they bought all the clothes that
structure remember structure yeah I do
or structure do you definitely want to
strut old-school rocking structure still
around yeah no it is nuts
if there is there's like two left you
I've changed their names to express them
so it's not still around they can just
express now yeah there's not a mother
out it's not around did you ever see one
black Asian dude on fresh
never never never man and I don't like
seeing that kind of stuff you know I
just think you gotta throw in some
diversity at least on Seinfeld they had
that um The Soup Nazi that neighbor yeah
Soup Nazi yeah Simon feels all day baby
actually son I felt was all whites
no it wasn't bro you at the Soup Nazi
yeah who was that guy sure what was he
he was uh Kuwaiti yeah I think so yeah
Iranian Oh German Nazi I didn't think
about that no there's calm soup nuts he
was in Charmin bro Soup Nazi ethnicity
are you yeah everybody know didn't know
soup for you guy but um but it was all
white Elaine was why George was white
Kramer always maybe he's white he was
Jewish I don't know if he Lane was
Jewish might have been better thanks
juice I think they're all juice what
about George suka stands as well yeah
yeah so that's the only thing I read
David wrote it extremely funny yeah it
was basically funniest bro yeah it was
kind of just like yeah it was it was uh
I'm still going Seinfeld over friends oh
I think Seinfeld was much more
entertaining to me way more for sure
alright with August on sort of a friend
zone fans agree 54% yeah I thought most
people pick friends people love friends
really it was you know Matson [ __ ]
couch and she'd get a job you do just
the 10 of us was a good show you ever
see that no we talked what else you got
so many hot chicks on it do it else
alright so this is changing it up a
little bit Ryan Hough damn growing that
[ __ ] northern Arizona would you
rather another red die of starvation or
participate in cannibalism survival only
last resort
none of this recreational cannibalism
which one is record gang gang gang
plants yes weed plants Jermaine Tomatoes
baby yeah I thought they were [ __ ]
parsley
um I would eat your ass if I had to talk
first of all you can start anywhere in
the body so maybe oh really
yeah pick a wrist or something no [ __ ]
you I'm not
yeah wrist I'm leaving your the cheeks
of your ass you guys ever seen the movie
alive where they crashed the plane they
just started eating jerky ass yeah yeah
bro there's a reason for that
that's where all your muscles at you
know I had a plane crash this is just if
the power goes out for four or five days
and we're [ __ ] stuck you how many
trash yeah well [ __ ] have something
else you put your elbows or ribs there's
nothing there you have this little
Kermit River have some of carmit ribs
did have the ribcage of a large cat dude
that's what they said when I was born
and I'll say this dude cannibalism all
day and you know I'm saying super easy
I'm not gonna die of starvation while my
friend just lays there [ __ ] all
edible yeah yeah looking all sweet and
delicious
my dad feels shitty I if I had and I
survived oh I'll get that gangrene I am
I'm talking about a little appetizer
what I'm talking about is this I keep
[ __ ] I've alive a glove box full of
condiments just in case the [ __ ]
world ends daddy cuz I'm not gonna be
that person first of all out there
eating somebody with no dipping sauce
yes plan [ __ ] I need that spicy mustard
I even dump a little bit of [ __ ]
misty barbeque on that yeah that honey
[ __ ] rare bro oh dude not start
everybody knows I almost been into a
Vietnamese guy to Best Buy one time yeah
I'll pickle your ear oh [ __ ] I'm saying
though it's like and I would start Asian
I would start Vietnamese I would start
my ocean why are you going with maybe
for dessert because they wouldn't they
wouldn't be as upset with you if you did
it again I'm not trying to eat some if
there's an angry black girl she's gonna
get [ __ ] pissed you try to bite into
that [ __ ] she's gonna be upset I'm
gonna save Hawaiian a very peaceful
person from Laos or what's another place
an Asian they're just gonna lay down a
sacrifice if and never like okay thank
you oh thank you yes at least it would
be under fully housing yes and fully
healthy yeah except happenes too much
fish the mercury poisoning yet you got
to think ahead you got to think ahead
that's why I think you bite into
Hawaiian pineapple
yeah you don't think like that do wise
Minzy what's that what's a Hawaiian song
it they always play oh that's not the
way with will be heavy we'll be having
ribs um Hawaii's a perfect place to do
cannibalism man number one they taste
like [ __ ] mahi-mahi and I know yeah
are we [ __ ] good and yeah I would do
cannibalism so I go I'm going on
cannibalism brah everyone agrees with
you 72 percent yeah what okay that's not
everyone what psycho 20% every 100
people most people all right sorry now
it's why my aunt Oh
[Music]
all right this is Angel's mission her
name is aunt Dee Oh goddamn aunt Dee Dee
her name is Dee aunt Dee goddamn D got
them double D's what's up girl
holla at your boy Andy um what's her
name just told you I thought that was
her nickname
Edie you know listen uh your titties are
in my face first of all I noticed first
of all if you see on the left she has a
child or a small Asian man hiding behind
her or is that a seal hey Nina seal with
ha that's a seal bro that's a seal with
the ano that you gets computer her hands
yeah that's a seal then check out our
[ __ ] best buy Polaroid camera for
sure get an iPhone miss that [ __ ] D
first of all you can't I think she's
trying to look too sexy with that kid
being right there that's the only part
that kind of alarms me the Hat is very
stupid jeff probst yeah she reminds you
of like if Jeff Probst got a sex change
but you're he's still [ __ ] because he
looked way good now very dumb and
Dumberer had when he walked into the
[ __ ] sure looks a little bit like she
looks like actually like a little bit
like the Topanga that we talked about
last who a little bit she has some nice
eyes lips oh I'm not mad to braid it
here to the side teeth look at that
extra-large scrunchie wrapped around the
tits buzz buzz boner I'm boned up right
now do you want to see that heater damn
bro I knew it I [ __ ] knew it
I know one feels gonna pop that boner
boy [ __ ] know it
I can feel in the air I can do did that
[ __ ] bro she did do that actually that's
pretty quick you auntie's okay thank you
and however wasn't the kid in the
background I'm also on a couple grams we
know man I took a couple yesterday make
some by agra just in case [ __ ] pops off
no I took that indi I'll get that stuff
from India makes your legs sweat but
makes you [ __ ] you know it'll keep
you up you know and I'll tell you to
make a feel excited you know I'll walk
around you boned up you're ready to just
kind of a fun game to play yeah you know
it's like a real whodunit
oh wow who might do it well this is a
hot ass want my shout out what's up girl
she's hot but I mean it's like yeah you
flaunted her do what's her name Janet
aunt Dee any day oh Jesus Christ dude
I've asked for Anthony's yeah Denise bro
Oh straight-up DCAM DG's yeah very nice
outdoors getting some vitamin D so
that's good maybe that's why they call
her that
you know maybe it looks like he's
vitamin D deficient action in the
background no he looks very dark I feel
like he's good to go oh that's a small
man it could be a lot of water you know
man I keep telling you it's how to seal
with human hands let's move on alright
shout out to [ __ ] out dee dee thanks
for giving our next one is from David
this is his aunt and uncle no it isn't
that's what it says no names but just
aunt and uncle
god damn bro like a peaceful couple huh
that boy on the right that uncle looked
like he's the wildest man in the world
look at that here bro you're talking
about that [ __ ] kiss haircut he is
going on uh yeah he looks like looks
like he can eg odg
Amen boy Kenny goddamn so yeah you look
he's got this hello it's like girly boy
he looks like the mascot for [ __ ] the
Golden Corral yeah I can bird up and
then the his aunt though is that it's
kind of a do you get a Native American
vibe from the aunt like was she dressed
like that
why'd he dress her up as a are they
playing cowboys and [ __ ] Indians no I
think they're from Montana or something
and maybe she could be American Indian
you know a lot of people from that area
have American Indian heritage in him
Nick just texted me that this is their
wedding photo oh it's beautiful yeah
last year is it a theme Cowboys in India
no why not bro he's not a cowboy he sure
is [ __ ] an Indian yeah she's an Indian
he looks more like a cowboy this bows it
looks like this looks like um to me it
looks a little bit like glamour shots
but in that's a fake background bro yeah
look st. glamor shots on Bunker Hill
that's what it looks like a little bit
yeah look kind of suspect he said
they're alaskan - oh there you go
that makes sense there you go so you
ever she's Inuit then they call it Inuit
she'll be eating whale blubber alright
oh yeah and he really seemed like a
cutting guy little [ __ ] has trouble
digestion or actually that could easily
digest a [ __ ] heavy chili you think I
see I think we feel like his insides are
rotten and then also no bail
goddamn bro no belt yet some nerve
rockin them dad jeans that you up from
Walmart with no belt
but he's a savage move he probably made
them himself dude it's obviously
Marshall she made them and she also made
that leather outfit out of [ __ ] human
skin as well no one knows the old
leather bra she definitely has that sort
of like who did her wedding dress
buffalo bill that has that Apocalypto
vibe going on about it I'll just I can't
put my [ __ ] finger on the pulse but
look at the hole that's him on the right
you don't know well you don't know how
to trust others then I think it's a you
issue I'll say this I trust any man that
can keep his pants up just by sheer
magic oh it's called right bro um yeah
their hands we help beat their hands on
and look how in love they are to dude
and he has more fingers than you should
have bet you anything they're divorced
no no
that doesn't stop whatever they're doing
what else we got shoutout to aunts and
uncles getting married in Montana a
beautiful couple this is why do it to us
bro why you do it to us
more than [ __ ] look that thing is real
you thought you talking about that
[ __ ] 24-hour Fitness whoa whoa zoom
in on that champ no you gotta zoom in
chin is there dick yryr nice Oh Rick
it's a man why Arnie is a man there's
nothing there go back
dude that is a woman bro no going on the
face dude that's a woman I'm very moment
goon dude that's a woman on hormones
dude that's Johnny Carson that's a woman
on hormones bro this is Skerritt top
this lady
dude dude this looks like look at the
hand zoom in on the hands chin it says a
lot you know what says Gold's Gym that's
what her hands say who's a really strong
person named Michael this looks like
Bret Michaels Bisping dude look at this
[ __ ] picture again okay
look how jacked and strong and also Bret
Michaels this person is it looks like
tits or not tits man you can't do that
and just say it's tits no you can't hide
- this looks like a game at Dave and
Buster's - whoo that's going on I don't
know where to go with this bro I just
what is going happen on look at the belt
the crud of man kills you look at the
whole [ __ ] Janna look at the powerful
jaw look at the [ __ ] dick in the
front look at the man hands look at the
24-hour fitness body baby that thing is
about picograms you talking about miss
Pico right now that's miss Piko Piko
baby oh this is a lady who's definitely
like doing lines of uh probably garbage
a sauce of playing with a [ __ ] riot
paavo lines a plant-based protein powder
you know in her car she looks at typed
Atticus you like the girl did you in
middle school and lifts you up as the
dough yea-ah
I chose fun era su ro yeah she would
[ __ ] wrap my legs on her it was so
weird kid hit him no no huh she was very
very nice girl too do you look like your
name's Tanya but goes by Tony they
actually call her uncle Sheila I told
you look at those hands baby bro there's
no look at the arm look at the dude that
is a woman who has been on many many
hormones yeah although that chest that
makes it different don't it yeah see
that stomach chest area that's very
massive right bro and those tits are way
too hard look at that arm it's not a
woman's arm look at the bottom of that
arm going into the hand that is 8 you
know what deal you're right bro thank
you brother don't [ __ ] touch me
especially when you have one eye
well hey and we're looking at a uncle
I'm putting the patch down on this lady
she doesn't pass over my eye for this
one is that there's the Weiner for the
flounce and face - Kelsey right for
sending this one in thanks for a splash
uncle Sheila is it really it looks like
they're in uh and looks like they're in
Denver but here's the thing I'll tell
you it was this Spokane Washington this
beautiful little you know I appreciate
the hard work now clearly a gym rat it's
clearly a gym rat bro and clearly takes
her protein at the right time of day
right after a workout has it ready to go
and the sacrifice and discipline to get
that body is nothing we should all just
pass by I agree I mean it's easy for me
to sit here with you know one eye
and the [ __ ] and an erect penis and
judge this person and uh but to actually
get out there and do the work to shave
your arms and shoulders touch a shave
your tip every day yeah and dress like
just you know like Wyatt slurp every day
to dress like the [ __ ] didn't Naked
Cowboy in New York every day you're
alive alright it's a dress like [ __ ]
that's like
WWE Diva during your normal life yeah I
mean this is definitely I thought this
is Brett might be the first P to I
thought was rock a love promo I thought
they're bringing the season back yeah
this is like crack rock I love all right
shout out to the yeah Thank You Cheryl
Sheila Sheila all right you guys ready
for can you understand hell yeah
buttons please hell hell hell hell yeah
Oh
[Music]
won I won I won I won I won
bangerang rufio oh it's so crazy how
you're how different my brain is no joke
when it's like this and you can I say
some not offend you you seem smarter
with one eye really yeah are you serious
yeah seems smarter like your IQ went up
24 Jesus I feel no joke mentally
impaired when I only have one eye
really cuz I think it's part is getting
used to it see I feel like there's a
mystery and like you seem educated with
one eye whenever you got an eye patch I
think he's been through some [ __ ] read a
lot of books and it's very fine whiskey
really yeah wow I feel like drives a
[ __ ] s-class Mercedes and lives in a
high-rise oh it's so hard to drive on
one eyebrow you're just you you're just
back and forth like this cuz you need
one out of you both I didn't think about
that so hard dude so I patches what do
we got alright first ones from Jose
Rivera [ __ ] is good I got our king of
the sting for the Rat King and the be
king you know be keen sting [ __ ]
cutoff jean shorts can get your sting it
let's get a [ __ ] look off me shorts I
love that guy man
you know chiapas kid is that baby out is
that a little el chapo let me tell you
this brother bear okay jorts first of
all I don't trust a man that wears
shorts to church so I don't care I don't
know if George so I don't even know what
it is
Jesus shorts or whatever shorts for
Jesus whatever you know I'm saying you
wear pants to go see the Lord son if I
see a man in shorts in church dude I'm
calling the police
I mean I'll report his license plate
yeah I'm with you on this as well
unless you had a pool you should not be
in shorts I'm sick of dudes wearing
shorts on planes at the [ __ ] food
taffeta fair at the fair at the pet
store okay get up kids don't wear shorts
bro should only wear shorts if you're at
the pool yeah I'm not trying to see your
junk your [ __ ] quad your ass cheeks
hanging out the bag you with sandals
it's immature bro
yeah tighten up dude or tighten out bro
boom
[ __ ] cutoff jean shorts so definitely
stinging it shut up the El Chapo alright
next one the tacos are so nothing bums
me out what else we tarnish a from
Huntington Beach put some [ __ ]
dang it blinkers so you know blinkers
are you know required by law whatever
it's courteous and everything I thought
was a race you changing lanes to turn
your blinker
when [ __ ] is gonna speed up he's not
gonna let you in and how many times are
just one ass on the road you're gonna
get five or six so you know use your
blinker you make sure it's safe that's
probably the option I'm saying Kingdom
Steen buzz-buzz bro this is America we
use blinker circa and if you don't use a
blinker it's so [ __ ] rude
we just jarred over it's so [ __ ] up
man you gotta use blinkers that's also
how you get rear-ended we're not using
blinkers nothing just dart over yeah I'm
gonna read from bro Jamaica Jamaica
doesn't use [ __ ] bleachers bro look
how it's turned out for them all they
have is Hussein ball that's it yeah any
tried to get out of Jamaica by running
out of there yeah he ran out of there on
water all they have is [ __ ] Hussein
balton jerk chicken yeah and I'll say
this I'm gonna [ __ ] raise the roof
for this yeah the eyes out baby
bangerang rufio Johnny Depp jizz boy
[Music]
I'll say this young fella who definitely
looks waste guest out in a stolen
vehicle obviously if you guys could see
this or not there's a very is two guys
this is like obviously this guy's the
Laotian Derek Fisher who's right there
and he yes blinkers dude yes you used
blinkers
forgive me I thought blinkers were
people or as a racial slur for people
with dry eyes but I I use it I use
blinkers man I demand other people use
blinkers if I see somebody who's not
using a blinker dude I will tail them
I'll follow them and when they finally
get out of their car whatever two three
miles later whatever I'll say hey you
have a blinker on back there and they
look at you like you're the [ __ ]
psycho but you know in your heart that
they're the bad one you know what's
right blinkers are right
farting on planes you know what's right
dude that don't do it do not awake a guy
up last week and [ __ ] tell his ass
stop farting did I woke him up yeah in
front of me but he farted like probably
13 times and I kept smelling around the
dude next to me and finally he was
[ __ ] this beached [ __ ] walrus of a
man a disgust and his wife sat there
next him the whole time like hit like
years ago she'd [ __ ] never spoken up
about and and I won't you marry
Craster's bro are you [ __ ] serious
you know I'm sitting right behind you
bro what'd he say huh
you I know that you bro you fart and
brog and tighten up dude
we're all we all got to breathe this air
and that'll gross and he didn't do it
the rest of the plane good for you good
for you Malcolm bro don't touch me what
else we got
mr. Scott Vaughn sup guys this is Scott
from Baton Rouge Louisiana they had a
question for King at our sting it what
do you guys think about the SEC Tamizh
it's a touchy subject
it's a [ __ ] move bro plate dot if God
won't you have more kids fire that
[ __ ] sticky-icky and your girl man
and they'll figure it out don't don't
[ __ ] up God's plumbing and tie that [ __ ]
off I fire them loads and play to play
the game dude the game of life busloads
that's the way life goes okay damn oh
damn dude um hold on I've totally
busloads that's the way life goes okay
bro it's your bypass has made us both
smarter rope yeah I'm gonna leave bind
down I don't want to see any more
there's some drop in the [ __ ] back
on you yes loads that's the way live
garden was forgot it okay first of all
dude yeah you look like dude you look
like Tony Robbins at a [ __ ] Division
three school okay let's be honest about
that I'm gonna raise the patch up and
tell you this guy
Dexter guy who's in scrubs in his own
house and is obviously doing BL bootleg
vasectomies back there in the Dirty
South in there in the Baton Rouge right
now if I 10 dude off at alpha Bluebonnet
your earn me okay I've been over there
dude I've busted nuts all up and down
Interstate 10 and I'll say this I'm not
gonna stop and if you want to get your
tubes tied or whatever you want to do
who would let you go in your body and
tie your [ __ ] tubes dude huh yeah
just control yourself how about this
tell your husband to bust outside of you
yeah I'll get a little bust couple days
just bust on your face I'll have some
respect no I thought look what happens
to people when show guys that's always
eyepatch gang just busted her face bro
you don't need to have a whole [ __ ]
surgery to sit figure it out
yeah dude here's what I say let the Lord
work and here's the but here's a scarier
thing a lot of times you go to some of
these jack shacks and he's massage
parlors and we're doing is Brad dude
they busted my buddy out put the semen
in like a warm bowl and [ __ ] left
with it
oh and start selling to people yeah
good-looking dude I bet yeah there's no
I've seen a hundred times so they're
[ __ ] they're jacking your jack bro so
you got to be careful of they don't
forget a vasectomy it also comes with a
[ __ ] Mini Cooper cuz you up [ __ ]
yeah so you should be driving
yeah dude you might as we just might as
well get a little bag of [ __ ] skittles
and [ __ ] put a bunch on your throat
just all yellow starbursts in a Prius oh
my god dude no vasectomies sting it but
go Tigers dude imma say so yeah I busted
a girl alright this one's from one beat
there or petrie
oh nice what up Brandon Brandon bro can
you sing it College do I know you were
home schooled in Brandon you look like
you don't know what the [ __ ] school
is can your sting it College gang gang
just college in general you look like
you're looking for a real life advice
from Lutz
College look I used to sign in college
or military probably don't take advice
from the two of us now do have a double
major yeah I do you - yeah I do bro from
UC a Colorado ever heard of it yeah big
deal oh never heard of hideous so uh
call it depends what you want to do cuz
a lot of times defend what you want to
do you're just gonna quiet unless you're
Blaine [ __ ] athletics and paying for
your school just can get a shitload of
debt and they got to pay all that [ __ ]
off and it's a nightmare
it depends what you're trying to do bro
try to be entertainment I don't know if
you need college degree it's a good plan
B and I would think about what
experience do you want brother if you
want an actual experience of you know
getting out on your own and like you
know you know becoming part of like a
bigger community
I mean colleges has tons of experience
you can't get anywhere else that you can
only get at college you know it's a
great experience
yeah you're gonna meet a lot of new
people Network you'll find out what you
like network all kinds of groups like
you look like you might be into dudes or
girls you're gonna find out if you go to
Arizona State dude you don't wake up
with a dick in your mouth yeah that's a
week that's college yeah or a diploma in
your hand brother I mean doubt it
there's a asking king of a sting to go
to college now you're gonna make it so
what I would do is go to Community
College and buy a [ __ ] pack of Hot
Tamales you shut the [ __ ] up just get
him you'll figure it out robot go to
college no it's a great time yeah
whether you're finding what you're gonna
do or not do it and don't worry I
wouldn't worry about the debt man here's
what's gonna happen with the debt you're
gonna build up college debt you're gonna
get loans you're gonna pay $100 for the
rest of your life so every month for the
rest of your life that's you're gonna do
so I wouldn't let this big balloon
college debt man I've never had a bunch
of money and I've always been able to
pay the hundred bucks every month
because I'll pay it till I die I want to
a bunch of college so I know but just
you have this debt but what college was
it University Arizona dude oh you did
yeah for four years note one okay yeah
so give me too much debt huh and
Louisiana State over there yeah on to
Loyola University as well that's a Santa
Monica College College of Charleston
that's for five master at c6 and
semester at sea and hold like a little
sea monkey there's one more dude I can't
row it I don't know Harvard that's seven
go to college where you figure
I'm telling to me a great time it go -
well you're just sitting in your car go
to college agree dude looks like your
frat boys gonna have a great time play
intramural sports and get way too
serious kick up a me to charge bro get
an STI have fun yeah dude II get it why
don't you get [ __ ] uh what's that
disease you get in your crotch a sex no
softer one gonorrhea yeah once you get
that [ __ ] gonorrhea in your eyes that
drip drip you get that drip in your eye
bro deep boy I'll get that rain drip in
your eye all right what else after that
dude last one from Matthew scarf hey
Brendan hey Theo Matthew here from
Adelaide Australia
I caught a king of this thing if he's
stretched earlobes what do you think
king of this thing it cheers boys cheers
man and I'll see you in a May I'll be
there in Australia awesome ah gauged
ears I mean sometimes it's a fun topic
conversation but actually living with it
you bet you mean you got nuts axe
hanging off yours I feel like it's a bad
idea there's no going back either you
putting rims in your ears bro where I'm
from if people got that when I was
growing up it meant they didn't really
get along with their mother and so that
was usually the thing that people got
but now I know it's more of like it's
almost gotten more tribal people want to
get their tattoos and get these lobes
jacked out but here's the thing a lot of
dudes a lot of gay dudes are getting
them and they trying to shoot semen
through the hole yes again so that's
telling it's hearts for gay dude yeah
but they bust on your neck and get them
whole but that's the side effect is
bullseye that's how they try to get you
they're like oh let me see if I can come
through that little ear and you're down
to do it and you're like oh I'll let you
try but here's the thing they're not
even really trying to because it's kind
of hit you in the face her head you
dropping knowledge tonight brother so
really you're an idiot and then you're
getting your meat and men but now if
that's what you want both and that's
what you want but I think if you put
information on there you know at find a
way to make them actually of value you
know but just a hole through your ear
where I can already see on the other
side of your ear I already know what's
behind your ear because I can see over
there easily just about going like there
was never a mystery
I never was curious about looking
through yeah yeah yeah I don't saying
you're not even solving any crimes here
but I think it's brave though I think
it's brave and I think it's wild and it
them the Maasai warriors do it over
there in a Apocalypto Apocalypto does it
as well in the movie Apocalypto you're
basically the Zebras of mankind like you
want to stick out when you do that you
know I like it I think it's a way to
flaunt yourself but do something
different put a spear through your
[ __ ] head or something do you know I
can put that put the [ __ ] dinner
plate through your lip like they do in
Africa yeah drop that deep play you know
what I'm saying what are you doing yeah
dude I want to get you want to be
different
drop that [ __ ] side dish in your
lower lip yeah dude
swallow a couple baggies a coat why not
[ __ ] eat a gallon of potato salad
film that put on YouTube dude do
something edgy man look I'll tell you
about that one of the edgiest things
I've ever seen they had a guy in my town
when I was young and I don't condone
this behavior but he made a bunch of
hats right standard hats standard hats
right they say they had the n-word on
the front okay but on the back it said
just joking across the back that's a bad
idea so but I'm saying if you're gonna
get wild and do something you need one
of those attention yeah I see what
you're saying cuz he people would see it
and get pissed and he would turn around
oh my god just joking they probably got
beat up so yeah you got a business plan
yeah so don't do anything like that but
do something unique for yourself do now
dude pierce your dick yes you're dead
bro
here's your dick P do tie your [ __ ]
run a chain from each one of your nuts
to your [ __ ] to your eyes yeah run
the chain to your [ __ ] yeah yeah yeah
head dude chain here [ __ ] chance hold
of your nuts yeah and do something
different than fulfillment yeah get out
there bro you know I'm saying it wild
bro you got the Orlando Magic Jersey get
while
yeah dude put a [ __ ] put huge
splinters of wood in your [ __ ] spleen
but yeah do any of that but y'all like
it man I like your attitude I like I do
- you're a brave man [ __ ] I'll say
Kenneth Australia I'll say King at to
shout to Austria shout to koalas cause
have herpes you know that yeah yep
shout out to this dude word to your
mother also shout-out to Zach Judah I'm
calling shooter Zach Judah cuz he's the
man who created the King and the sting
design he's done a bunch of designs for
me he's worked with frickin Nike ESPN
Marvel Comics adidas ever heard of it
old food
dude he specialized in in illustration
branding apparel he does it all
he's our boy he made this shoutout to
him exact it him up at Zach shuddha
ink.com he's at Zach Judah Shu ta Zach s
H UTA on Instagram he's the man he's
always helping us out shout out to our
boy Zach Zach I'm gonna king zach is
that it dude that's his attention out to
that beefy amp bro giving you a boner
shout out that G give me a boner shout
out to one guys with eye patches
yeah man shout out to everybody that's
only rockin one eye and I'd love it if
one of you guys were sending a video for
next week so we could get a little bit
you know King at her sting at two eyes
or one eye I shout out to aunt Sheila
with that [ __ ] shout out to do the
invisible dick and that [ __ ] hard
body out there
shout out the FEMA female yeah shut up -
emails and feet um female and females
dude and mailman yeah and that's a
mailman and mailman man dude this was a
fun one this is a good one bro you
really you really held it down for us do
cuz I'm feeling I don't know what
happened to me do my I went out and I
don't know what's gonna go on with the
rest of me dude I was gonna text this
and we can at this that we don't leave
said I would so I have to start all new
material right and I'm doing writing new
material and come up with new bits and
stuff and I was thinking the way my
brain works and doing the show
challenging me so much man it gets me so
out of my comfort zone cuz I have to try
to keep up with you which I can't do
because you're so creative but I try and
keep up with you just help my stand-up
it's helped much really everything yeah
man
watch your beast yeah I appreciate
that's nice even things like it's like
if you're a basketball player and you're
in you're playing basketball you know
trying to keep up with a [ __ ] LeBron
or you know Kyrie Irving left shrimp
him - or John Stockton with if you're
not constantly around that you get
better you know you have to step your
game up that's what you do for me
brother well thanks dude it's easy I
mean well that's nice you to say that
man touch me dude King this thing baby
thanks for listening subscribing
the sponsors everything we love you guys
yep and I'll be back next week with two
eyes and we'll really be taking it to
town some shows coming up in Boston
though - yeah yeah we're adding new
shows in Medford
February I think 6th or 7th you'll be
able to check those out and yeah man I'm
sure I don't know March 6 or 7 I don't
know when it is but they'll go on sale
this week and they're gonna be in
Medford go see when the best in the
world then I'm in Miami end of March
Miami improv and then at the very end of
March 22 the 30th in DC washington DC DC
improv get tickets go see teal go see
the bead sting yep yep yes love you guys
[Music]